[Music]
the California city of Fresno is foreign
sixty miles of zet and on the verge of
bankruptcy cover Lewis Cole offered to
help solve Fresno's financial problems
by giving them a tourist magnet this
thing draws huge crowds wherever it is
the world's largest bobble head Nick
Conan bobblehead well Fresno until you
get your act together financially the
conan bobblehead stays here I don't want
to leave you empty-handed so in the
meantime I'm sending Fresno this equally
exciting Andy Richter bobblehead check
it out and then this is gonna be an 80
regular bobble head look at that
right now it's Edgar Allen Poe found
dead in the streets of Baltimore outside
a polling place on Election Day he was
42 years old suffered from alcoholism
related maladies I don't think so don't
loan this guy money he's not good for it
you've disappointed me
look this is Eisenhower trying to tell
you and your poems
mother please letter get your pink lips
away from mother I wrote one about her
raven quoth the raven nevermore you make
me sick what it I stormed the beaches of
Normandy
[Music]
Normandy sounds like a girl's name I
could use it no pollen I said quiet
[Laughter]
[Music]